c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soit il est bienvenus sur France 24 à la
une ce soir ces images de kibomba cette
ville au centre des combats entre le M23
et les FARDC hier les rebelles affirmés
qu'ils en avaient pris le contrôle les
autorités congolaises avaient démenti
pour l'instant les combats font rage
dans cette ville à une vingtaine de
kilomètres de Gomma nous écouterons un
membre des forces de l'ordre dans ce
journal
ces expulsions d'étrangers en Guinée
équatoriale depuis quelques semaines
elle se multiplie les ressortissants
camerounais renvoyés chez eux sont
nombreux le pays affirme expulsé des
étrangers en situation irrégulière alors
qu'il a acté en 2017 la libre
circulation de personnes entre la
communauté d'État d'Afrique centrale
reportage à suivre et puis la cop27 qui
touche à sa fin et l'agriculture est au
cœur des préoccupations sur le continent
un secteur polluant et à la fois très
impacté par le réchauffement climatique
et le dernier verrou sécurité avant la
ville de Goma chef-lieu du Nord qui
voulait combat à l'arme lourdes font
rage depuis quelques jours les fard
c'est les forces armées de la République
démocratique du Congo ont même engagé
deux avions de chasse contre les
rebelles le M23 qui affirmait hier avoir
pris le contrôle de la ville ce que
dément l'armée congolaise et les forces
de l'ordre écouter
de suivre
c'est que c'est pas une somme sous le
choc des batailles comme tel au front
dans nos militaires sont là
vers qui
à la population de façon
qu'elle soit calme
l'armée est entrée disons que de
travailler comme ses doigts
effectivement que la police est sur
place là où se trouve l'armée
hier on vous montrait des images du
deuxième bataillon enseignant déployé à
Goma dans le Nord qui vont en République
démocratique du Congo une centaine de
soldats de la force régionale est
africaine envoyé sur place pour lutter
contre les milices rebelles du M23 qui
se livre à d'un temps ce combat je vous
le disais contre l'armée congolaise une
de nos équipes a pu prendre l'avion qui
acheminait ses soldats à kenyan de
Nairobi vers l'Est de la RDC reportage
signé Bastien renouilles
deux mois après l'autorisation du
déploiement de la force est africaine en
RDC ces troupes kenyan sont missionnés
pour combattre dans le Nord qui vous et
ce n'est qu'à quelques minutes de
l'embarquement que l'objectif de leur
opération se précise
nous n'allons pas affronter les groupes
hostiles
en premier lieu nous allons créer des
conditions favorables à une solution
politique
c'est un objectif très important
nous devons aider les forces de sécurité
congolaises à désarmé et démobilisé les
belligérants
sans hommes qui vont être déployés à
Goma ils vont superviser les opérations
de la force est africaine et vont aussi
préparer l'arrivée des troupes
combattantes kenyan qui devrait poser le
pied en République démocratique du Congo
au cours des prochains jours
le Parlement kenyan a approuvé l'envoi
de plus de 900 soldats mais la façon
dont ils vont coopérer avec l'armée
congolaise ne semble pas totalement
définie
beaucoup de choses vont changer et nous
allons évoluer dans une mission
offensive
afin de ramener la paix dans notre pays
la RDC avec un priorité les M23 si la RD
Congo souhaite attaquer le groupe
rebelle le Kenya semble plutôt tourné
vers la mise en place d'une stratégie
défensive
en tant que commandant de cette force
tout est très clair pour moi nous sommes
ici pour protéger et défendre l'aéroport
international de Goma
ainsi que le quartier général de l'armée
pendant que le processus politique suit
son cours
difficile de dire pour l'instant combien
de temps cette opération de
stabilisation de l'Est de l'ère décès va
durer les troupes kenyan et les troupes
de la force est africaine ont un mandat
de 6 mois un mandat qui pourrait être
renouvelé si nécessaire
depuis quelques semaines des centaines
d'étrangers Africains vivant en Guinée
équatoriale des Camerounais pour la
plupart sont expulsés vers leur pays une
situation incompréhensible puisque la
Guinée équatoriale a signé en 2017 un
accord de libre circulation avec les 6
états de la communauté économique et
monétaire d'Afrique centrale pour
beaucoup ces expulsions sont liées à
l'approche du scrutin présidentiel en
Guinée équatoriale il se tiendra ce
dimanche reportage de nos correspondants
Marcel amoko et lucarmel G
quelques matelas épars et des détenus
couchées à même le sol nous sommes dans
une prison de montgomo en Guinée
équatoriale sur cette vidéo amateur
postée sur les réseaux sociaux des
ressortissants camerounais jetés en
prison en attendant d'être rapatriés
dans leur pays une vidéo qui a poussé
beaucoup d'autres immigrés camerounais à
rester terre et chez eux et à lancer un
appel désespéré aux autorités
camerounaises nous sommes bloqués dans
les maisons nous sommes bloquées n'a pas
possibilité de sortie c'est vrai le
consulat pour les engagements mais ça ne
suffit pas les Camerounais nombreux en
Guinée équatoriale venez nous aider
sur cette vidéo des arrestations
musclées d'étrangers qui se poursuivent
en Guinée équatoriale rapatria Yaoundé
se perdent quatre enfants a choisi le
témoigner sous anonymat par peur de
représailles son épouse vit toujours
caché en Guinée équatoriale où il vient
le passer deux ans il a été expulsé du
pays comme des dizaines d'autres
camerounais à l'approche de la
présidentielle du 20 novembre un retour
amer pour ses émigrés qui rêvaient d'un
aile de radio économique en Guinée
équatoriale et qui sont revenus chez eux
sans rien ou presque j'avais ce t-shirts
sont en confiance ils sont là ce n'est
pas facile déjà qu'on revient à la case
de départ parce que c'est ici qu'on a
que j'ai passé tout mon temps j'ai fait
tous mes études dans la maison et je
suis parti de la maison pour la Guinée
conte plus qu'après les études
depuis le début de cette nouvelle
campagne d'expulsion 83 ressortissants
camerounais ont déjà pu regagner leur
pays dans le cadre d'un rapatriement
volontaire facilitée par les autorités
camerounaises mais il en reste encore
plusieurs centaines sur place leur sort
préoccupe des militants des droits de
l'homme comme Caroline
gobazacs
dans le sens où on est en train de les
poursuivre comme des animaux on demande
à la Guinée équatoriale de respecter les
traiter qu'elle a signé elle a le droit
de mettre si elle veut dehors mais en
respectant tous les traités
internationaux les autorités équatiques
que ces expulsions visent les étrangers
en situation irrégulière mais des
activistes dénoncent une opération liée
à la prochaine présidentielle
[Applaudissements]
ce nouveau rebondissement au Bénin
finalement le grand parti d'opposition
de l'ancien président Yayi Boni pourra
participer aux élections législatives du
8 janvier prochain la Cour
constitutionnelle a donné raison ce
jeudi au parti les démocrates il avait
déposé un recours après sa
disqualification par la commission
électorale tout le parti avait été mis
hors de hors-jeu parce que quatre
candidats sur les 218 n'avaient pas de
quitus fiscal dans leur dossier la Cour
constitutionnelle a demandé que la Sénat
prenne en compte une liste bis
des nouvelles de Allah belfata depuis le
début de la COP 27 que ce soit son
avocat ou sa famille personne n'avait eu
accès aux prisonnier politique le plus
emblématique d’égypte cet après-midi des
membres de sa famille ont pu le voir il
a arrêté sa grève de la fin mais reste
extrêmement fragile ok la correspondance
des doigts de Roxy
extrêmement affaibli qu'on pue voir sa
mère sa tante et sa soeur ce jeudi
après-midi à la prison de Wadin atroom
c'était la première visite depuis le 24
octobre lors d'une conférence de presse
elles ont expliqué à quel point il était
amaigri et affaibli donc depuis plus de
7 mois à la delfata avait commencé une
grève de la fin mais le début de la
cop27 il avait même arrêté de boire
c'est pour cela que les autorités
pénitentiaires l'ont alimenté
artificiellement dans son récit sa
famille raconte aussi à quel point il
s'est mis en danger il s'est frappé la
tête contre les murs
passant très très proche du coma et s'il
s'est remis à s'alimenter Sana sa sœur
se dit quand même extrêmement inquiet
pour lui
maintenant nous ne sommes plus inquiets
pour sa santé physique même s'il a l'air
fragile mais plus pour sa santé mentale
qui est très instable la manière dont
ils opère à la prison est très cruelle
ce n'est pas forcément le personnel mais
les ordres qui leur sont donnés qui sont
très cruels et strictes
les chefs d'État se sont succédés auprès
du président égyptien Abdel Fatah
al-sissi pour demander sa libération
mais cela ne va aucun effet sa sœur se
dit extrêmement déçu par ces
personnalités politiques et dit ne faire
plus confiance à personne et sûrement
pas à la Grande-Bretagne dont il a
pourtant la nationalité
la COP 27 touche presque à sa fin il est
préoccupations autour du réchauffement
climatique demeure parmi les grands
dossiers celui de l'agriculture
l'auto-suffisance alimentaire fait
partie des grands débats surtout depuis
le déclenchement de la guerre en Ukraine
grenier du blé l'agriculture est l'un
des secteurs les plus polluants et en
même temps l'un des plus impactés par le
réchauffement climatique pour en parler
notre invité à math Pathé ciné expert
des questions de changement climatiques
pour l'Afrique de l'Ouest au FIDA le
fond international de développement
agricole bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
alors tout d'abord l'agriculture est
responsable je le disais de plus du
quart des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre comment aider le continent
africain à produire plus pour nourrir sa
population tout en produisant plus
propre plus durable
merci beaucoup merci pour cette
invitation et il est important de
rappeler qu'aujourd'hui malgré donc ces
statistiques sur le réchauffement
climatique
des émissions de gaz à effet donc
l'agriculture en soi n'est pas forcément
la prix les émissions ne sont pas en soi
la priorité pour l'Afrique mais c'est
beaucoup plus l'adaptation puisque
actuellement la majorité de des gens qui
sont dans l'agriculture c'est des petits
producteurs qui sont extrêmement
vulnérables au changement climatique et
qui produisent un tiers de la
l'alimentation mondiale ces derniers la
majorité en Afrique c'est 80% et c'est
les clés de la sécurité alimentaire mais
malheureusement c'est fond eux qui font
les dégâts des différentes crises covid
la crise actuellement
ukrainienne mais également tout ce qui
est crise économique et la majorité de
ces populations aujourd'hui ne reçoivent
que 1,7% de la finance climatique donc
en soi en termes de justice climatique
qui n'ont pas créé qui pas les capacités
de s'adapter au cœur des débats il y a
donc l'adaptation sur la table et
aujourd'hui récemment au Nigéria 1,2
millions de personnes déplacées avec les
inondations sur la Corne de l'Afrique
donc un certain nombre de communautés
également qui sont affectés par les cris
successives dans le Sahel et ça fait
beaucoup qui aujourd'hui donc fait le
narratif des livres africains au niveau
de la COP mais également tout ce qui les
appuis particulièrement ce qui
produisent et là si on ne fait rien dans
l'avenir avec bien sûr les projections
climatiques si on ne sort pas avec un
accord en tout cas
malheureusement il y aura des pertes sur
les rendements pour aller de 10 jusqu'à
50% à l'horizon 2011 alors certains pays
ont choisi de passer vidéo aux OGM c'est
le cas du Sénégal ou en en parlait hier
du Kenya craignez-vous que de nombreux
pays soient obligés de faire ce genre de
choix pour éviter la famine
alors le choix des OGM c'est en fait un
choix des pays donc pas forcément le
choix de l'institution que je représente
donc c'est vraiment un choix pour chaque
pays et aujourd'hui on peut produire
plus et mieux c'est un côté pour autant
passer par les OGM mais c'est il faut
faire de l'agriculture durable
brésilienne et avec bien sûr des
technologies adaptées produire en
culture hors saison et à utiliser des
techniques simples ça peut être
également des techniques endogènes qui
sont comme des techniques connues de
l'agroforesterie mais aussi l'irigation
goutte-à-goutte dans des zones où la
ressource en eau peut être mobilisée
donc tout ça pourrait être fait pour
pallier bien sûr aux pertes de rendement
mais pouvoir bien sûr augmenter les
productions et nourrir les populations
africaines et donc ça avec l'adaptation
et également les techniques
d'atténuation et de modernisation de
l'agriculture alors
très rapidement l'Union européenne a
promis à un milliard d'euros au pays les
plus impactés par le réchauffement
climatique n'est-ce pas un peu dérisoire
alors dérisoire puisque actuellement en
Afrique les besoins d'ici 2050 et
annuellement ces 50 milliards donc on
est très loin il y a eu beaucoup de
promesses et donc c'est des promesses
bien sûr de 100 milliards depuis
l'accord de Paris en 2015 jusque là on
est très très loin et donc de Coop
encore je pense que la discussion
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment comment te
dire ces promesses là et faire de sorte
que ça soit une réalité donc c'est bien
venu les 1 milliards donc de l'Union
européenne mais je pense que les besoins
sont encore plus importants surtout dans
une Afrique où il y a eu quand même
actuellement sur la table on parle donc
des pertes au dommages à la Coop pour le
campus payer lorsqu'il y a des dommages
et des pertes engendrées par ces
changements climatiques des pays riches
vers les pays pauvres donc à ce jour
maintenir en tout cas les le
réchauffement à 1,5 c'est sur le texte
c'est déjà une bonne chose sur
photographe mais l'adaptation doit être
également au cœur les pertes au dommages
ont été donc le sujet des discussions et
nous osons croire que d'ici demain il y
aura bien sûr donc des accords là-dessus
merci beaucoup à Mathieu scène expert
des questions de changement climatique
pour l'Afrique de l'Ouest au FIDA merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions et c'est
la fin du journal de l'Afrique rester
avec nous l'info continue sur France 24
[Musique]